[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
my wife and tom
more than one year later disgraced south
carolina attorney alec murdoch is
indicted in the murder of his wife and
son and actor kevin spacey enters a plea
as he faces charges of sexual assault in
the united kingdom when he came out of
the court i wouldn't say he was
interacting in any way with anybody who
was outside he seemed to want to get to
the car as quickly as possible plus a
group of children turned themselves over
to police after allegedly beating an
elderly man to death with a traffic code
and later colorado versus kevin eastman
she doesn't know and he just kept going
and
he raped
her
and i feel bad speaking it was again
jurors are shown the defendant's police
interrogation law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
your host brian buckman after months of
speculation a grand jury indicted
disgraced south carolina attorney alec
murdoch for murders of his wife and son
law encrimes angie olivia is here with
more on the charges internet
brian alex murdoch faces two counts of
murder and two other charges for the
deaths of his wife maggie and son paul
back in june of 2021. now maggie and
paul murdoch you'll recall were found
shot to death on the grounds of the
family's hunting estate murdoch called
9-1-1 and told the call taker that his
wife and son had been shot the crime
scene the crime rather sent shockwaves
through the low country of south
carolina because the murdochs were a
prominent family they were a long line
of lawyers in this family
and there was more to the story though
as there often is in cases like this it
came to light that alex murdoch had a
serious drug problem and was being
accused of taking money from the estate
of his housekeeper gloria satterfield
and others he faces more than 80
criminal charges related to that case
satterfield actually died at the home of
the murdochs and it was called a slip
and fall accident then he and another
man this is you get where it gets even
crazier we're charged in a plot to make
it look like murdoch took his own life
so his son buster could collect the life
insurance money from his death attorney
susan williams talked to us about the
possibilities a possibility rather of
other family members knowing what
happened to both paul and maggie murdock
the other parts of the murdoch family
have no one else has been charged with
anything so i certainly
wouldn't speculate on that and you know
i think that
without them if no one has been charged
that would be defamatory to to jump to
that conclusion
but certainly alec murdoch has
had
an absolutely unprecedented
series
of events that no one knew about and
they're all coming to light now anywhere
from um
extremely serious white-collar crimes
and now we learned today
violence
crimes of violence murder
now murdoch's attorneys issued the
following statement in response to the
indictment it reads alex wants his
family friends and everyone to know that
he did not have anything to do with the
murders of maggie and paul he loved them
more than anything in the world it was
very clear from day one that law
enforcement and the attorney general
prematurely concluded that alec was
responsible for the murder of his wife
and son but we know that alec did not
have any motive whatsoever to murder
them we are immediately filing a motion
for speedy trial and requesting that the
attorney general turn over all of the
evidence within 30 days as required by
law and we demand to have a trial within
60 days of receiving that evidence so
that's very quick murdock will actually
be arraigned on these murder charges
next wednesday he remains in jail being
held without bail on those other cases
brian
thanks angenet joining us today is legal
analyst karen nance co-host terry austin
and of course angina levy karen what new
evidence went into bringing these
charges
well the person who made the 911 call
was alec murdoch in addition the
forensic edit evidence showed that there
was some blood spreader
at close uh in a close proximity to
where the
blood was on his body and and on the one
of the victims it hasn't really been
identified which one either was paul or
maggie the mother and so i think that um
there's also the idea that he mr murdoch
didn't want his um son to testify or or
go to trial with the case with a milery
beach which was scheduled to come up in
the next month or so
prior to their death so i think that
that's what they're going to
that's where the prosecution's going to
focus their attention in terms of motive
and also the fact that there was
forensic evidence on
alex's body it's interesting that you
that you pose like that that's what the
prosecution's going to focus on because
terry my question for you is kind of
what the defense would focus on why do
you think it took this long to bring out
charges uh and could that affect the
prosecution's case going forward
well there's so many moving parts to
this case brian that it's going to take
the authorities a long time to put it
all together they have to figure out the
motive and that means they're going to
go backwards i don't think it's going to
hurt the prosecution because the mother
and the son died just a year ago or so
and i think that it's still fresh enough
but they're trying to figure out what
happened to all of these other people
that we've been mentioning so for
instance stephen smith the young boy 19
year olds who were found on the road
gloria satterfield the housemate who was
you know tripped and fell allegedly
mallory beach who died in the boat
incident you know all of these people i
think they're looking at to determine
whether or not alex murdoch had any
involvement at all and trying to figure
out what the motive was behind the death
of his wife and son yeah now andrea the
a.g isn't saying anything about the
evidence but we know something about the
weapons used what is that
yeah a lot of times brian you'll see in
an indictment in a criminal case
especially one as serious as murder it
just lists the charges just enough to
notify the defendant of what the charges
are but in this case they actually gave
us a couple of little nuggets here one
being that maggie was shot with a rifle
and paul was shot with a shotgun so two
different weapons were used in this case
and it really makes you wonder how this
could have gone down if they're saying
alex murdoch was the one who pulled the
trigger and was the murderer um did was
one killed first and then the other
brought out we don't know we're going to
have to wait and see what the state's
theory of the case is yeah that's
strange why different guns like shoot
one put get another gun
we'll see how that plays out as a case
continues thank you everyone
and in new york r b artist r kelly filed
a notice of appeal this week in federal
court this comes just two weeks after
the singer was sentenced on racketeering
charges at the end of the last month
r kelly was sentenced to 30 years in
prison after he was found guilty in
september of leading a criminal
enterprise which recruited young women
girls and boys for sex prosecutors
alleged kelly's sexual misconduct went
on for decades the charges also included
a bribery scheme to get a fake id for
the late singer aaliyah so that the two
could get married when she was just 15
years old kelly claims he believed deleo
was pregnant at the time the appeal
filed monday in new york federal court
did not say on which grounds kelly
intends to challenge a verdict and
subsequent 30-year prison sentence in
addition robert kelly is transferred to
a federal jail in chicago this week the
rmb star was indicted on 21 counts of
child pornography in a state court and
was acquitted years later by a jury jury
selection for a second federal trial in
chicago is set to begin august 15th
still ahead on law and crime daily a
group of juveniles turn themselves over
to police after allegedly attacking an
elderly man to death with a traffic
company but first kevin spacey appears
in court overseas what plea the actor
enters in his sexual assault case
[Music]
welcome back academy award-winning actor
kevin spacey pleads not guilty to
charges of sexual assault in the united
kingdom spacey who appeared in court
overseas on thursday entered the not
guilty plea at the central criminal
court of england in wales the actor
faces multiple charges of sexual assault
dating back to 2005 2008 and 2013 with
three different male accusers at the
time of the alleged assault spacey was
the artistic director at the old vic
theater in london this isn't the actor's
first run-in with claims against him
he's faced more than a dozen sexual
misconduct allegations since 2017.
spacey's acting career came to an abrupt
halt when actor anthony rapp accused him
of assaulting him at a party when rapp
was just a teenager law and crime
network spoke with united kingdom
solicitor lizette aguilar who described
the scene outside the historic
courthouse and what's next for spacey
i think that the fact that he
voluntarily came to the uk to be
formally charged in the first place and
that he has again appeared in person
um
really speaks to
his confidence
that these charges will be dismissed
having said that they are very serious
charges and he will have to go of course
through the whole trial process
when he came out of the court i wouldn't
say he was interacting in any way with
anybody who was outside he seemed to
want to get to the car as quickly as
possible which is understandable
on thursday a british judge ruled
spacey's trial will begin on june 6 2023
and could last three to four weeks space
maintains his innocence
terry spacey is facing charges that are
9 to 17 years old how will the age of
these allegations affect the prosecution
and the defense
you know here i do think the age of the
allegations are going to affect both
sides time is the prosecution's enemy
here and it's generally speaking going
to be the defendant's friend these are
old charges and the memories fade after
a certain amount of time and you know
those memories can also be attacked and
i do think the defense will try to
attack the memories of the witnesses
here of the victims here and also don't
forget physical evidence might have
disappeared at this point we don't even
know if there'll be such evidence as dna
evidence and witnesses may be long gone
so time is not going to help the
prosecution but at the end of the day i
think it will help the defense here yeah
karen right the judge set a trial date
for june 6 of 2023 lasting about three
to four weeks so what happens from now
till then
well the defense has to get their case
together by getting as much evidence as
they possibly can in terms of discovery
motions they'll be requesting for
example cell phone records and i believe
they made that request of the
prosecution so far and trying to place
uh mr spacey at the locations of where
these individuals the three different
victims in this case were at the time to
either corroborate
whether he was even in that location and
if he wasn't uh then they would move
forward with the motion to dismiss but
it probably is not going to be that easy
but in terms of gathering all the
evidence that they can in terms of
discovery would be their best bet and if
it turns out that there's not enough to
move forward they'll make a motion to
dismiss
we'll keep eyes on that case as it
continues coming up on law and crime
daily kevin dean eastman stands trial
for a colorado double murder plus two
teenagers charge in the death of an
elderly philadelphia man will they be
tried as adults
[Music]
welcome back to 14 year olds are charged
with murder after a group of juveniles
allegedly beat an elderly man to death
with a traffic cone in philadelphia on
monday a fourteen-year-old boy and his
ten-year-old brother turned themselves
in to the police the ten-year-old was
released but the 14 year old richard
jones was charged as an adult with third
degree murder and criminal conspiracy
charges on wednesday a 13 year old girl
and a 14 year old girl also turned
themselves in the 13 year old was
released her attorney now saying she
tried to stop the attack
fourteen-year-old kamara mosley was also
charged with third degree murder all
this comes weeks after the attack caught
on video by security cameras the footage
shows a group of seven kids beating a 73
year old man with a traffic cone while
police did not release his name local
philadelphia news outlets identified the
73 year old as james lampard jr who went
by the nickname simi security video
shows lampard being struck by the cone
and falling to the ground he died the
next day
terry with so many suspects under the
age of 18 how's the prosecution deciding
who is charged as an adult or a juvenile
well under pennsylvania law it depends
on the crime and it depends on the age
of the child pennsylvania law says that
the child can be charged as an adult if
they're at least 14 years old and if
they're accused of a felony and juvenile
court may actually transfer the case to
adult court and as you mentioned these
two 14 year olds have been charged with
these crimes so they will look at each
case individually and determine whether
or not the crime should be charged as an
adult based on that person's age the 10
year old obviously is not being charged
at this point others could be charged as
adults but we'll have to wait and see
what the courts say as to each and every
one who comes forth and gets charged
karen with so many potential defendants
will it matter who held the cone who
delivered the deadly blow or will they
all be charged the same
well i think that it depends as as terry
said on
the totality of the circumstances and
that includes whether any of these
juveniles had cases ahead of time what
was what is their family situation and
we're looking at accomplices or
accessories right during the fact not
after the fact what happened during the
fact and so the video that we're now
watching is imperative to identify who
did what in the situation and the police
can move forward and d.a can move
forward from there so it does depend on
you know if i if you walked in there
once and then you and you step back uh
does that mean that you're it's
exculpatory probably not uh if you
stayed the whole time and and the fact
is it's 2 30 in the morning and none of
these uh
young teens should have been out at that
time so i think it's going to take a lot
for the da to go through piece by piece
individual by individual to figure out
who should be charged with what yeah
still developing a story but of course
as we get more information we'll be here
with you long crime daily to give you
updates when we come back a colorado man
stands trial for a double homicide still
ahead we bring you kevin dean eastman's
police interrogation as the state begins
to wrap up its case
welcome back new details are emerging
about how a texas yoga teacher evaded
police for weeks after she allegedly
murdered an elite cyclist officials
allege caitlin armstrong shot and killed
mariah wilson in an austin apartment
while she was in town for a bicycle race
on may 11. investigators believe it was
a jealousy fueled killing over a past
relationship armstrong's boyfriend colin
strickland had with wilson they say
armstrong fled the country to costa rica
after the murder she was found 43 days
later and looked quite different from
her former appearance police say they
discovered a more than six thousand
dollar receipt for cosmetic surgery
inside a lock box they believe was
armstrong's court documents reveal she
had access to nearly half a million
dollars while on the run which was given
to her by strickland as investment
capital they also show armstrong had
allegedly visited a gun range before the
shooting death of wilson authorities say
armstrong used three aliases while on
the run to avoid being caught
switching now to colorado as the state
is expected to soon rest its case in the
double homicide trial of kevin dean
eastman after jurors are shown the
hours-long police interrogation with the
defendant eastman is charged with two
counts of first-degree murder tampering
with the deceased human body and
tampering with physical evidence for
allegedly killing his ex-girlfriend
heather frank and her new love interest
local musician stanley scott sessions
authorities say they were killed on
separate days in february of 2020. frank
and eastman both had arrest warrants in
connection to sessions murder before
frank's body was found prosecutors say
eastman slit sessions throat in frank's
apartment and that eastman fatally shot
frank in the chest twice to silence the
only witness to sessions killing they
say he then hit her body on the property
of his new employer troy bonnell who
testified this week investigators say
eastman burned session's body and was
allegedly preparing to burn frank's body
when he was arrested at a nearby gas
station in his interrogation with police
eastman said frank told him sessions
sexually assaulted her
okay so who who didn't want to have sex
in that in that account i
really wish that
i feel like i'm like betraying the trust
if i tell you well it's easier that you
and i talk about it for when i go and
talk to her i just say hey look you know
i heard that there was some sort of
contact between you and this guy named
scott
and it was unwanted and i believe in
that
yeah he went over to her house
so i think that um they've probably been
seeing each other for a while okay
yeah
all right so the question is who didn't
what was it her was it him
well
okay she told me that um
she doesn't know and he just kept going
and then he raped
her
and i feel bad speaking ill of it yet
right
that's not very polite
um
then i feel bad breaking her confidence
so like i said i don't know how
believable that is because why would you
go back and see him after that
i mean which i wanted to yeah
and would
you karen what did the interrogation
video reveal that hurt the defense
i think that we have inconsistent
statements that mr eastman made he was
questioned for hours right so there were
inconsistencies that the two uh in
interrogators asked and i think that
they the prosecution will be able to use
that in terms of strengthening their
case against mr eastman uh they drew the
diagram and and the other issue is was
he that credible did he come across as
really being uh saddened by the fact
that uh heather um yeah heather uh was
killed or did he appear to be the person
caught in the in
the act of being found out that he was
one responsible for the two murders so i
think that the jury has a lot to look at
there are hours of tape and i think that
it'll be an opportunity for them to
really analyze his credibility yeah and
terry will the prosecution soon rest in
the defense will have an opportunity to
put on a case do you think they'll have
witnesses testify and could that include
eastman
you know i think what the defense might
do here is just try doing their closing
statement to say that the prosecution
did not meet its burden i'm trying to
you know determine what witnesses they
could put on obviously they can put
friends up we know that the prosecution
put friends of heather franks up to talk
about her and her character etc i
suppose that the defense could do
something like that or anything to point
the finger at someone else they could of
course i guess get experts in to refute
the physical evidence but i think at the
end of the day they will not put him on
the stand i think he didn't come across
as karen mentioned very well in that
video who's to say how he will come
across on the stand and as you know
it's very risky to put a defendant up on
the stand particularly because of cross
absolutely well law and crime network is
covering that case so make sure to check
it out there and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you